Megadeth sauce with liquid rage oh yeah
that's the selling point uh hey what's
going on everybody for first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by Eric Andre
he's from the Eric Andre show yes and in
a lot of ways our shows are similar in
that we torture our guests for no reason
they'll torture the guests do you feel
like this is karma maybe in a little bit
of way I got so much bad karma coming at
me that I need to like cash in on it
this is cashing in on it 12:04 season
four coming at you down at your quick
yeah all right you ready to do this
No
it's like [ __ ] sossel in my face I'll
look out for you don't tell me deliver
so with your show you have some guests
who can really roll with the punches no
and then you have others that become
visibly hostile yeah Lou Ferrigno stands
out to me yeah I wanna go there a lot
Lauren Conrad stands out to me out I
need to know like what's the most
chaotic scene you've ever had when it
all cuts what's really Lauren Conrad she
wasn't like thrilled I puked on the
Destin I hate up the puke I mean you
know what's not easy for anybody T I
walked out a bunch but he ended it
better than Lauren Conrad that he walked
out like think two or three times or in
the interview and I had to keep seducing
him back into my why does he walk out
there's a lot of full frontal nudity
what do you say to bring him back
we're almost done we're almost own world
was done which is sorry Kurt never
blonde sociopath we're like an hour and
a half from being done cuz we shoot each
interview for like an hour and a half
and we Whittle it down to like the best
three four minutes I read that one time
and I was actually shocked to read that
it's that long torturous it's torture
it's hell for everybody never getting
nothing I'll do a shot of this right now
don't do a shot of ink so that's the
hottest song I'll do a [ __ ] shot of
this right now I'll [ __ ] vacuum clean
that shoot my dick hole death
easy I need more of a challenge dude
it's gonna get there it's gonna get a
college in Bangkok do you understand no
you didn't you wouldn't Massachusetts
yeah address your research you know
there's the studio version but then you
also go out on the field mm-hmm and I
have to think that you have ideas that
either Adult Swim legal or producer say
like no no no no no we can't do that
we have this prank we wanted we wanted
to have a transgendered man [ __ ] a
transgendered woman next to a camera the
while I was interviewing a celebrity and
just not mention to build them and our
lawyers are like yeah you can't do that
and then we're like oh what about like a
transgender woman taking a [ __ ] next to
a camera while the interview is going on
and we don't send me an animal just act
like it's normal
no he's like no you can't he's like here
here is promo he's just trying to keep
me out of jail which I've been too
however I've already been arrested on
the show I almost got arrested again
this year so how'd you almost get
arrested
I've been legally advised not to discuss
this is all you katako caribbean
habanero no what the [ __ ] you just said
you speaking Cajun so you're a spice
glad you can handle it so what's your
challenge sometimes I think I have a
pretty good tolerance one time I ate a
Carolina Reaper which is the hottest
pepper in the entire world really yeah
size of a strawberry ate the whole thing
how was that it was like giving yourself
food poisoning for no reason at all it
not gonna [ __ ] out so sick so sick I
need I don't know what my bottom dollar
would be to ever do it again but it
would be like five figures I wouldn't do
it for less than so make me sick sick
painful dying oh yeah yeah yeah so I
know that you went to the Berklee School
of Music your coho is Hannibal he's on
that open mic Eagle song
no finger waves except baby face LeBron
James needs to stop taking HGH his
hairline [ __ ] up from the HGH have you
guys ever thought about making music
together have you ever had any yeah we
always just do go out around about
putting on a mixtape and I've been
making some [ __ ] on Ableton for like the
past 10 years
never put out blood I'd love to music
industry's gotta [ __ ] dad so it's like
hard you know it's hard to get motivated
cuz I'm like do I want to pay year's
worth of work into something that's
gonna make no money but uh I'm down [ __ ]
it
money's overrated right you have a
couple bucks to spend at this point
right I make like toe tree hundred
dollars a week from Cheers I know you're
big wu-tang clan fan huge wu-tang clan
fan have you ever put your name into the
wu-tang clan name generator' no but
that's how childish gambino got his name
apparently well did you know that I put
your name into the wu-tang clan name oh
yeah what is it
it is Prince ambassador what that's weak
you don't like it Prince ambassador it
sound like I work for the embassy
what would your persona be you think I
don't know maybe I would be the only
member of the wu-tang that could produce
breast milk if you're making a rap
supergroup who would you call on you
think hmm steelo Julio
mmm positive K the guy that's saying
what's he man got to do with me I got a
man Julio did this shelf-ready mm-hmm
god bless him what he did was he took
the last sauce this one oh and he was
like dumped it on the last wave like a
paint can oh and then he cleaned it oh
and then he was facedown in our green
room in the back of a couch for an hour
Coolio just passed out so no matter how
much milk you do you can't the thing is
is I've noticed it's like you know
professional wrestlers yeah often times
when they get their cockiest that's
their downfall when I start showboating
to the crowd you know and I've noticed
that on this show as well when guys
start to not respect the wings not
respect the hot sauces that's the mark
of their downfall when you're gonna give
me a hot one dude all right this is
[ __ ] mild not hardcore
this one is number five and this is
actually our hot sauce so the show is
called hot ones we actually have a
hopper you look at you and I'm not
joking when I say it's the best hot
sauce that's ever been made but I'll
leave that up to you that's this wing
right here what do you do with vegan or
vegetarian slippery so we had on we're
gonna walk a flock of flame on he's
ready he's vegan yeah which is wild
right Waka Flocka intriguing Waka Flocka
is vegan but vote on my [ __ ] line so
we had to get tofu and we're gonna put
you know tofu hot ones but he ate like
too many edibles the night before and
ended up getting hospitalized oh my god
so we had to cancel his shoot we had a
bit on the show called waka ayahuasca
Flocka Flame we're gonna secretly give
him ayahuasca and then like wait an hour
and try to get a wrap he didn't
directorial so you know there's like a
free the nipple wave on Instagram yeah
and you're kind of a trailblazer in the
magic people been writing about it
recently but I followed you for quite
some time and this is not a new
development I remember for years I would
just be schooling like oh there's Eric
Andre if I can make it again last time I
put my dick I was in Japan with snow
monkeys and I was butt naked at a in a
hot spring with a bunch of monkeys
[ __ ] and pissing in a hot spring I
was in like a piping hot monkey toilet
put the picture on Instagram and it was
up for like a whole day 24 hours up and
then my friend put a picture of him
wearing like a I had nothing on his
boner picture got taken down in like two
hours so I think that there's someone at
Instagram on my side so prophecy is
fighting for you fighting for me is
there a reason behind it just goofin I'm
just like I'm a 13 year old size of
humor it's also a rush it's like a holy
[ __ ] and then you know what else you do
on Instagram sometimes and somebody says
something mean in the comments you'll
put them up on your thing and go [ __ ]
I put him on blast did the comments
upset you or like why like didn't will
[ __ ] [ __ ] on me hard and some like an
oculus picture I put up I'll get ripped
to shreds and I'll be like [ __ ]
I'm read this [ __ ] like you're just
you're saying as to me there's no filter
i'm reaiiy put up a picture i read the
comments and you tele be like 17 reasons
why i should go to hell
I was like you want to go to war I'm
ready to go to [ __ ] war and you take
it and you go to war and I go to war do
you find that these guys cuz here's what
I base always apologize immediately
that's I am me and they'll be like I was
just joking around I'm a huge fan even
though they told me like 16 ways why
like I should kill myself and why my
show sucks and why I suck and where my
comedy sucks
no instantly 180 and be like oh I didn't
know you read this I'm such a huge fan
it's like you're lucky you're a liar
what do you think it motivates that well
I don't know there's a bunch of [ __ ]
lunatics out there paid 100 sucked it's
the worst one I think it's the worst
money I don't care we're here for
another hour and a half I don't care if
Coolio has to come back in and stop me
I can't believe me [ __ ] dump that
[ __ ] on Casper you got nothing simple
huh all right you know what I used to
and I appreciated it and I think as I've
gotten older I get it less yeah thank
you Eric you [ __ ] hog have you had
anyone women on the show Tinashe how'd
she do so how you saving him after him
yeah I hit her up on the deal she didn't
write back what you say you know the
classics I want to get you pregnant what
you have my daughter no response so it's
very contentious between me I want to
know about Japan because you know
everybody who goes to Japan always talks
about how they love Japan and those are
people that don't even get to drink the
Hornet so did you like you did my cherry
or I showed you what was like the
craziest thing you did in Japan you went
to that restaurant that has the robots
how is it robot sorry [ __ ] a robot
that is [ __ ] miserable
Tinashe where are you wearing this is
actually literally the worst hot sauce
I've ever had in my life don't ask him
million Oh doesn't have any flavor it's
the worst
it tastes like shitty Tabasco I hate
Tabasco you invented some sex moves
recently but you stopped yeah that was a
good idea
about that you invented some sex mazar-e
I'm going through some paid 100 but you
stop is like p90x figure tongue you stop
short of explaining them so I was hoping
I could bounce them off of you and then
you can show this by sure that it stays
yeah if it just went away be cool I
can't believe it was about to do a shot
of this yeah and I can't even get pens
when I talked you out of it they look
good they do have blood written down for
the count
what's a French exit alright exit you
know what so Bali is nobody's Wed like
you come in your wife's mouth energy
French kisses a packet you're about
that's projects it is so Bali but when
you replace it with poop what's a tuxedo
surprise ohhh tuxedo surprises a French
exit while you're wearing a tuxedo what
is a potato boy potato boys when you
have sex with Haley Joel Osment that is
paying 100 [ __ ] you pay 200 you don't
even taste good taste the pain how about
you taste the flavor taste the pain pain
100 real clever marketing you [ __ ]
[ __ ] at this point I'm just asking
you questions on a pure curiosity
because I'm like a little bit ahead of
you so I just don't know okay tough guy
you want to [ __ ] uh you want to go
you're playing in my [ __ ] macho
insecurities I know I'm gonna regret
this I have very very small penis and it
was not small not a small I've seen
about a hundred times I think on I think
on the plus side of average I'm gonna
[ __ ] eat out your camera operators
you hear that boys when you're the wild
guy when you hit the room everybody
expects you to probably go nuts right
yeah
is that a burden is that a curse what's
the worst thing about being Eric Andre
the crazy guy I'm a man of extremes off
camera I'm very like the sedated an Adam
I meditate twice of that a jog
or therapy I need salad so this is hot I
literally I was getting a bond me in
Toronto and this kid came home to regal
Eric Andre ah
they started punching me in the back as
hard as he could I was like dude it's
11:30 in the morning
I'm eating a Vietnamese sandwich like I
love you I'd appreciate you but you got
turned down a couple notches this is a
[ __ ] nightmare
do you regret doing it yeah but [ __ ]
mess number 9 is called Mad Dog 357 oh
yeah can't wait I'm the first season of
our show Mad Dog 357 now it's our second
hottest sauce it looks like the [ __ ]
artwork for from a [ __ ] lost Snoop
Dogg album
are there hot sauces like you can't even
rub your eyes afterwards you know what
else you got to watch out for if you
take a piss afterwards you gotta watch
out don't touch your dick I was gonna
jerk on your that's bathroom afterwards
already told I'm so horny right now oh
my god
my buttholes on wet this is mad dog 357
oh great can't wait not I love you
ah you're starting to kind of go nuts I
think when I look into your eyes it's
not the same eyes that I saw in wing one
we're on international waters out of
here man I feel like one of those like
deranged pirates get some come on
you fainted that's all you got yet I
actually love that you've reunited with
Lauren Conrad you have the same agent
went to my agency for a meeting going to
the bathroom talking my agent I see this
pretty blonde girl walk by can she make
eye contact make the nut she like moon
walks backwards out of sight and I was
like huh that was weird behavior she
slowly walks by me and she goes yeah hey
what's up it was like hey what's up
there was like oh I mean my age oh oh oh
I like look at each other that you took
up I was like couple Arcana and then we
just like sat there like this like
little kids and they would just start
dying laughing like yeah I ran away what
do you think this shows like hanging up
my uvula
but it's time delayed 2 o'clock yeah
they do they children or is it him ah
jeromy's bogan
so forget that [ __ ] dude the first bitey
to hurt her later I'll see you in hell
Coolio
there's something guess before the
interview
I need a [ __ ] guest during the
interview not today though and that day
is today yeah yeah we have throw up so
it's kind of tradition around here to
dab the last wing before you [ __ ] out
your goddamn mind you don't have to if
you don't want to we don't make you do
any of this I gotta give the internet
what they want
I feel like a bucket of [ __ ] you [ __ ]
out of your mind
nightmare pain 100 was like a cool
summer breeze
Britta's [ __ ] Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage oh yeah that's the selling
point uh-oh kyon isn't it made me sick
you don't have to do it you don't have
to dab it you don't have to dab it you
gotta give the Internet what they want
and true showman Eric I'm a showman my
father was a seaman
all right P all right Cheers air okay
dude I don't even [ __ ] eat mild Taco
Bell sauce and I'm doing something
called Cambodia deaf camp or something
whatever the [ __ ] the name of it is
cheers long human young you man
oh god I'm American five four one right
further one man is all you got looking
way oh my god come on
Oh baby no milk I'll need I don't need
where I'm going flavor country come on
hashtag Guy Fieri baby I feel truly
enlightened what's that girl's name Tay
Zonday Tina Fey Chocolate Rain
both bus cost a lot did Drake beating
the suck so bad
chug the raid we'll have that guy he had
that one hit he's as the one-hit wonder
don't you dare
Road you [ __ ] dare talk about my man
like that you have more milk yeah you
really taste the liquid rage of that one
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] K hole dude but
what's the like you just white grounded
why did they make the sausage so hot
chocolate raid season four of the Eric
Andre show it's coming out on television
da that's the best bug we've ever had
Pub days on day did I support this
message Donald Trump's gonna be presents
here the world's go to hell we got six
months to live
yo leo at once oh my [ __ ] lungs are
collapsing